Here's the entire solution. The main elements here are figuring out how to get
the elapsed time and how to offset the texture itself. About the only tricky
bit is the realization that if you want the texture to move downwards, you add
the time to the offset. This has the effect of moving the texture's frame of
reference up, which in turn moves the display of the texture down. My solution
is actually offsetting the v value a potentially huge amount as the time
increases. But it doesn't matter since the texture repeats. A less sufficient
solution is this. It's best to avoid creating new objects every frame, such as
this vector. Eventually, javascript has to perform garbage collection, which
can cause your animations to hesitate at intervals. Once I had the basic
solution, I started to play with the horizontal offset too. Giving this offset
a slight wobble with a sine wave made it a little more appealing. I also
changed the repetition length along the vertical axis by dividing the repeat
factor by 3. This gives a more stream-like appearance to the water. It looks a
bit like a rushing river or waterfall now. Look in the additional course
materials for my snippet of code and try it out yourself, then try other
functions. It's pretty addictive.